okay first of all you guys were so
incredible in your roles what does it
feel like to get so much positive
feedback and I feel an Oscar Nam is
coming for both of you so let's talk
about that
you go fast I mean I don't know so one
day at a time yes I just went to the
world to see it and see all the
reactions because right now it's only
people in related to movies and this is
a movie about movies so I really want to
see like the human connection because
the movies about movies but also about
the story of all these characters yeah
yeah yeah it's about
it's about people wanting to
be a part of something bigger as Manny's
character as Diego's character Manny
says I want to be a part of something or
feel something and I think when you sit
and watch this movie you do feel a part
of it like you it's really immersive
when you sit there and you're watching
Spike Jones pretend to be a German
director directing Brad who's pretending
to be Jack Conrad a movie star and all
that kind of stuff it's like you are
also on tender hooks waiting to see if
they're going to get this movie magic
moment and when you do when they do you
you feel it I mean there's so many
moments like that it's it's yeah so it's
not just that of course it's set in
Hollywood in the 1920s into the early
30s but it's also just about
yeah being a part of something yeah this
film Felt Like A Feast for the eyes yeah
there were a lot of naked people and
maybe you shouldn't order a meal when
you watch this film what was it like for
you guys on set because it felt and
looked Wild
it was wild and everything was real yeah
yeah women took care of that like he
likes everything for real the musicians
were reactional musicians like I think
the only part is the elephant yeah this
one is the only thing yeah everything
else was there yeah it was mental it was
so fun and everyone was so in it and it
was it was just so fun yeah it was wild
as wild as it is to watch it it was even
I mean that you're seeing an edited
version as well so like that party that
you're at for 15 minutes or whatever we
were there for two weeks like we've seen
some things
we've been in places yeah
um what was it like reuniting with Brad
in this seeing him again so good it's
the first time we've acted together this
is the third movie we're in together and
we don't get to do any scenes obviously
in the Big Shot we don't I just do a
cameo in uh Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood we we never cross paths this
is the first time it was so exciting I
was like Brad we're finally gonna do a
scene together yeah it was great yeah
what was it like for you working with
the queen over here well
first of all and I told you this before
I tell you this before but my the
greatest acting experience I ever had
because Margo is always putting the
level like higher higher and in this
kind of movie when Damian the director
wants even more and more and more he was
like a beautiful challenge but there was
a challenge every day in this movie like
even the quiet scenes like the so Damian
knows perfectly also perfectly what he
wants so even when you see like the
characters being quiet he's actually
yelling like more more yeah a challenge
the most beautiful one yeah uh Lily said
that she was surprised that you never
get tired you always give a thousand she
was taking she was sleeping you were
still out doing things where do you find
the energy
I don't know I find energy is like uh it
compounds when I'm surrounded by other
energies so like being in a potty scene
and everyone's giving it then I'm like
like I can't put a cap on my like
adrenal system I'd come home from work
and be like
calm down like you need to start
chilling out but even on the weekends I
was like in Nelly mode I was like right
we're going out we're partying
everyone's like aren't you working all
the time I'm like I know but I got to
stay up in Nelly Nelly's atmosphere and
I gotta keep going uh and then I totally
crashed at the end